hello rejects Craig over here and with
me is Sir John Bailey the epic voice guy
again need for introduction here we were
looking through some trailers and people
did ask me to check this out
and it's the Justice League dark
official trailer and you watch the DC
animated movies all the things I've seen
a strong man I've seen every single one
them but I've seen like maybe like seven
of them or something like that I really
do enjoy I like this well I suppose one
everyone keeps telling me to watch I'm
good and I'm a huge fan of the show the
flash so I would like to watch that but
Justice League dark I think this one you
have like Constantine in there and Swamp
Thing Swamp Thing getting some love nice
Swamp Thing yes especially these days
weird yeah that's funny one thing was
originally rated G with topless chick in
it like the actual like the one for
middle yeah I'm actually was rated G bit
at it was there was rating system so
chance oh jobs PG right yeah that was
back in the future that's crazy oh this
is PG wait what oh wow it's radar Wow
disturbing violence I guess they're
they're pushing the bar since the Joker
something from Game of Thrones sarens
beforehand the same pattern is repeating
around the world so there could be an
overriding paranormal element talking
about magic that we have to find John
Constantine
obviously it's Batman keep justices in
the shadows
this is justice and shadows there it is
right there that building minute in
appearance let's take a walk on the dark
side that that poise has never been my
character you do threaten the green
it's dr. strange that you're good
man-bat mats all over the Justice League
dark your life is the patchwork of
blackness with no time for joy how do
you cope with it I have a butler like
Joe let me work with the black and gray
degree since I Dortch floating a little
bit now that's a dude from
Star Trek the Patrick Stewart chicks -
my name is Gerry O'Connell's planes -
okay okay Batman versus Robin this guy's
done Batman yeah yeah I'm yeah that's
where I'm em because I knew that
recognize him from Teachers College
Justice League dark this still was not
as dark as the cars trailer she call it
Justice League dark but not as dark come
on over that cars no no we moved on but
man like Dawson as Wonder Woman she's in
Dishonored 2 with me Louis yeah yeah
they gotta meet her no yeah she she and
Vincent D'Onofrio or like the famous
people in that game I'm just like one of
the guys you can kill Wow it's hordes of
rats and flies yeah Claire and Wilson
fists in one game and Jerry Collins
music man for a while now Jerry
O'Connell super Matt O'Brien Delaney I
know how do you boys guys just get
together oh yeah it's a very tight-knit
group it's gonna drip chats on the phone
pretty much you stop at each other put
on different voices you're like the
Reservoir Dogs you know I'm gonna get a
bunch of boys actors together
I recognize the new 52 Justice League
they've kept everybody pretty much the
same it seems like they're this is an
all magic episode they have to do magic
because Superman is vulnerable to magic
because he's too powerful and they
finally found things that are that'll
hurt him
but it's a really cool good thing I
swampthing in there that's pretty
awesome I mean you know Marvel has like
dr. strange now so I wanna introduce
their magic Oh fitzy probably why they
made this no it's like a strange game
out there like we need to do a magic one
this is good marketing because I know
they're working on the Justice League
dark movie right now yeah I think with
doug liman directing right so this is
clever marketing etc' has always
dominated in the animated features I
would say even in the animated series as
well they've always done much better
than Marvel has absolutely absolutely
Marvel does better with their movies
maybe they're just like let's play to
our strengths yeah we can take a good
theatrical movie but we can make a heck
of a good yeah
anime new blu-ray the Dark Knight
Returns I remember being pretty violent
yeah and I thought that night returns
was great that's my second favorite next
to flash boy I remember that mean bobby
was pg-13 wasn't it should have been our
it really really fell are you killing
Joker's radar I think it seems like
they've been too scared to try to push
the envelope with animated stuff like we
haven't seen an adult animated stuff
before geez I finally did our with The
Killing Joke but it was like was it
really I'm hoping this goes all out but
I'm still watching us like hard our
stuff I know in the trailer because they
even had to make it red band but yeah
but but it's noise so so being re it
gives me hope that they will they really
will be a dark it will be Justice League
dark I don't know anything about the
dark characters do you like John
constant saying that paralyzed places
yeah I know they have this one and
there's their one little group of was a
dead man I believe is the the guy with a
terrible voice but he looks like a ghost
version of daredevil for some reason to
me yeah yeah till the worst costume a
dead man in there they're swapping
someone things cool i'm actually i'm
curious what they're gonna do with Swamp
Thing I always thought something was a
cool character I feel like John
Constantine is gonna be the like the
next big addition I mean yeah well they
have to they have to feature their their
doctor strange for Justice League target
it's kind of annoying to me that they're
making Batman still the front and center
of all this they have to that means the
best everybody's favorite no they are
dark characters but I kind of feel like
this is their version of Doctor Strange
yeah because it's almost the same exact
concept it's like whereas if you just
take the word Avengers and replace it
with Justice League where the Justice
League protects us from physical threat
yes protective a more mystical exact
mystical threats yes about the guys who
defend against the magic stuff so they
have to throw the Justice League in
there like for me for someone who
doesn't take the time out to read as
many comics as that like well I don't
read the comics anymore I just I've only
watched there maybe something so I could
have either DC animated movies a lot of
fans have said they're pretty accurate
to the actual source material I don't
know is this based on this specific
graphic novel of Justice League dark or
is it justified
I would I would assume don't quote me I
would assume that it's just based on the
comic stories usually yeah okay they're
not a graphic novel based they usually
deserve like all of their films have
been based on a storyline from comics
I'll definitely check it out yeah I'll
definitely watch it oh yeah let's go up
a heaven here must be good right yeah
the last line he said that was pretty
funny that was pretty funny I think they
did the same thing they did in the
Wonder Woman trailer we got jokes huh
but a Bing
but let's Rob it just pans over to right
yeah the funny thing about the DC
magical characters as they all are
pretty much the same as far as like
power they just look different it goes
back to all the hand waving alright guys
well sorry I can't really provide an
in-depth review that one you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to Jon
Bailey epic voice guy you took /c / real
epic voice guy as epic voice guy on all
the social things HTTP all that stuff
for the beginning before that - you
don't really have to type it in use type
youtube.com slash slash okay John lie to
me right now takes me a long time to
search the honest Channel there's a lot
of voices a lot of voices a lot of
character stuff a lot of oppression
funny stuff which is of course the
honest trailer voice guy of the screen
junkies yep he's also on an honest game
trailer Smosh and other weeds also
wheeze
he's also us working on the Spencer
anime he's also a nice man a family man
a social man he's good man he's good man
and he is his be John Bale and I am the
voice of Optimus Prime and the new
transformers cartoons oh well you could
lead to even bigger and better things I
really can't talk about I can't say this
is the outro and the this is the outro
subscribe to
real rejects yes two or one transform
and crawl out on now I'm just gonna take
that and put that off everyone in my
video outro